hello and welcome, i'm James Murphy. have you ever
added two floating point numbers like .1
and .2 and gotten something slightly off?
well in this video we'll find out why by looking
at how floating point numbers are represented.
thanks to this video's sponsor, anvil, a
browser-based full stack development platform
allowing you to make web apps with nothing but
python. more about anvil at the end of the video.
i'm using python but even if you're using
a different language like c or c plus plus
you probably got the exact
same answer that's because
most programming languages follow the same
standard for representing floating point numbers.
most likely your language uses 32 or 64-bit
floats. python uses 64-bit. i'll use the struct
library to coax python into showing me the bits
underneath the float. now we can see the actual
bits that make up the numbers .1, .2, .3 and the
sum of .1 and .2. i've put spaces in the numbers
here so that you can see the different parts of
the representation of a floating point number.
the first bit is a sign bit: zero for
positive one for negative. the second
and third chunks are an exponent and fraction
like in scientific notation. most of the time
here's what the number represents: we choose
the scale of our number by picking the correct
exponent and then we get the right digits by
putting everything else into the fraction, where
here 1.fraction is a number between 1 and 2 which
is "1." and then all of these bits interpreted in
binary. you can represent the numbers 0 all the
way up to 2047 in this exponent. we subtract 1023
from the exponent e in order to allow ourselves
to be able to represent both really big numbers
but also really small numbers. you can see
that 0.1 and 0.2 have the same fractional part,
which makes sense because 0.2 is just 2 times
0.1. so really i just need to increase the
exponent by 1. we also notice that 0.1 and 0.2 are
repeated decimals because 10 is not a power of 2.
but we only have 64 bits to work with, 52 in
this group, so that means the repeated decimal
got rounded or cut off at some point.
that explains why .1 + .2 is not .3,
rounding error. here's what one and negative one
look like. note that because there's a one dot at
the beginning of the fractional part that's
implicit we don't need to put that one in,
that's why the representation for one is
just all zeros in the fractional part.
the exponent is 1023 to offset the bias and
the sign bit is zero for positive. negative
one is the same with a flipped sign bit. and
here's what zero and negative zero look like.
that's right, negative zero. any real number
that has a floating point representation
has only one, except for zero that's the only
exception. the representation of zero is all zeros
and the representation of negative zero just has a
one in the sign bit. you can see that they compare
equal to each other but they're definitely not the
same object. this is different say from integer 0
and negative 0, which are exactly the same object.
you can also represent plus or minus infinity as a
float. infinities are an exception to the formula
from before. you just set the exponent to all ones
and the fraction to all zeros and then set the
sign bit accordingly. notice that if you take
a big number and multiply it by something you
might get infinity. you can also represent NaNs,
or not a number, in python using an exponent of
all ones and anything that's not all zeros for
the fraction. you can make a NaN directly or do
something like multiply infinity times zero. NaNs
are also one of the only kinds of objects that
don't compare equal to themselves. aside from
NaN's and infinities there's one more exception
to the rule for the formula for a floating point
number. basically when the exponent gets down to
zero you drop the implicit one at the beginning of
the fraction. this allows you to get a few more
powers of two closer to zero. but if you try to
go too far you will just hit zero. so what should
you do if you want to compare floats for equality?
well don't use equals equals. just look at the
absolute value of their difference and then check
to see if it's really small. basically you're
saying if the difference is smaller than this
then i'm just calling them equal. of course if
you're not okay with any error and you really
need an exact representation then you might
prefer something like the decimal library.
the decimal library is built into python and
stores your numbers as a string so they can be as
long as they need to be to get the exact precision
that you desire. of course if you're trying to
represent an irrational number like square
root of 2, you're out of luck. but if you're
only dealing with rational numbers and you really
need exactness, like if you're dealing with money,
then you should definitely use the decimal
library. storing decimals as a string may
take a little bit more memory, but obviously
it's worth it if you need the exact precision.
hey everyone thanks for watching, slap
that like button an odd number of times,
and if you want to hear about the
video sponsor, anvil, stick around.
anvil has everything you need to develop and
deploy a web app written completely in python,
including the front end, so no javascript or html
required. and it's free to try. create your user
interface by dragging and dropping components.
anvil's web-based ide allows you to develop in
your browser. no need to install anything. you
can use anvil's built-in database and let anvil
handle the tricky parts like user authentication.
when you're ready, deploy your app to the cloud
with a single click. check out the link in the
description to get started with anvil today.